authorities on both sides of the
atlantic are scrambling to slow a highly
contagious variant of the coronavirus in
the u.s top health official anthony
fauci is urging people to get booster
shots wear masks and reconsider travel
plans as the omicron variant spreads
that's as other european governments
clamp down on public life to battle the
new strain the netherlands has become
the first to impose a strict lockdown
over christmas
for many across the netherlands it's the
variant that killed christmas thanks to
the highly contagious omicron the
government has ordered all non-essential
businesses to shut till mid-january
christmas gatherings have also been
curtailed people will only be allowed
four guests around the tree on the
holidays for some the new measures were
a surprise
we thought we had it under control that
we'd done everything we could
we're fully vaccinated
you do everything you can to support
society a bit but in the end it all goes
wrong anyway
denmark ii has brought in new
restrictions amid surging curved
infections the variant already counts
for a fifth of new cases there germany
has also taken steps to slow omicron's
race across the continent severely
restricting travel from the uk where the
variant is rapidly becoming dominant the
country's health minister has said new
restrictions can't be ruled out before
christmas
beyond europe omicron also poses a
threat
omicron is increasing rapidly and we
expect it to become the dominant strain
in the united states as it has in other
countries in the coming weeks
in new york the epicenter of the us's
first coveted wave the variant is
already thought to be behind a record
increase in cases
authorities are urging people to get
vaccinated and boosted to avoid a repeat
of 2020
but with omicron already present in
around 90 countries and spreading fast
the world looks set to start yet another
year locked in battle with the
coronavirus
let's bring in peter chin hong here he's
a professor of medicine at the
university of san francisco in uh of
california in san francisco good to see
you dr chinh hong
we're seeing rapidly rising omicron
infections here in europe is the rest of
the world on a similar path
the rest of the world terry is
definitely on a similar path if not
worse uh we have to fasten our seat
belts for what will be a tremendous ride
if you think about three things that
will affect transmission and population
previous immunity we know that omicron
is five times more likely to be to cause
reinfection than other variants uh
vaccines have not had high uptake in
many countries around the world as low
as six percent which not protect and
don't even think about boosters and the
third is risk mitigation a lot of
pandemic fatigue a lot of uh mass not
where so i think we're in for a ride
well here in europe at least and in the
u.s as well most governments are pushing
people to get their third vaccination
but will a booster be enough to get on
top of this here
it wouldn't be enough uh terry you'd
still need the extra risk mitigation uh
factors like wearing masks
doing diagnostic tests but it does give
us the best armor if you think about
some of the initial studies 20
protection against infection if you're
presented with omicron
if you get a booster you can go up to 55
to 80 percent but again not a hundred
percent so you need the other stuff but
we do believe that even with two doses
you will be protected against serious
disease hospitalization and death
perhaps unless you're older in 65 or
immune compromised
you mentioned the risk of reinfection
earlier with omicron do we do we have
enough data yet to know how dangerous
omicron is
compared to the delta variant
well i think a study from the university
of hong kong or hong kong is instructed
in this regard they found that
omnichron
produces 70 times more virus in the
airways but when you look in the lungs
there isn't a lot of virus there
suggesting that it's very transmissible
without causing a lot of inflammation in
the organs
we do know that in south africa
in delta you get about 20
hospitalization with omicron two percent
a study in uk showed no difference but
even if you do think that it's causing
fewer hospitalizations when you have a
turbocharged uh transmissible virus
even a smaller percentage of a large
amount of people could potentially
strain hospitals
what advice
would you give people going into
christmas week
well i think about the abcdes is success
the destination you're going to high
amount of virus uh or and assess
yourself your immune compromise
unvaccinated or older in 65 you may
worry b definitely get your booster from
what we discussed uh c vaccinate your
children if they're eligible d do
diagnostic tests like rapid testing
before going in and any gathering uh
like a family reunion and e everything
else wear a well-fitted mask and get
your flu shot
dr peter chin hong thanks for talking
with us that was professor peter
chinhung at san francisco university of
california san francisco
my pleasure terry thank you
and for more on this story i'm now
joined by dr wolfgang pricer a
virologist from the university of
stellenbosch thanks so so much for
coming on the show now you're part of a
consortium that first detected the
omicron variant all eyes are on this new
variant as it spreads around the world
and as we've seen europe is struggling
to curb infections can you tell us what
the situation is like in south africa
it may sound as a bit of a surprise
because i mean i i see from afar that
that you know how europe is is really um
trying hard to to control the spread of
omicron which which is happening so fast
we are relatively relaxed and the reason
is that also our infection numbers shot
up from very low levels in contrast to
most of europe we had very low levels
before omicron came about four weeks ago
and since our in numbers of infections
are going up but fortunately uh our
hospital admissions are not keeping pace
so they are lagging behind and we are
actually in a more comfortable situation
than we were when we last saw this
number this high numbers of of
infections in our previous waves and we
think that is due to the fact that many
south africans became infected uh during
the previous waves of course many people
also died this is you know that is the
sad truth we lost many people who belong
to the high-risk groups but those who
survived plus the about third of adults
who have now been vaccinated they
probably have some degree of protection
against the severe cause of omicron
infection and that is what is so far
protecting our health care system so is
it fair to say that those people do
indeed have some kind of protection
against omicron i mean is the variant
different enough that people who have
already been infected and have recovered
can be reinfected again and is that in
any way affecting uh total population
immunity
absolutely it is i mean that is the
worrying aspect of this a new variant it
is very capable of infecting people who
have some degree of immunity and in fact
uh a recent study of ours has shown that
german visitors uh who even had their
biotech fisa booster doses still became
infected with omicron so so this virus
is very capable of undermining a
pre-existing immune response but we
still
you know we think what we are seeing is
that a previous immunity gives stove
protection against severe disease and
this is why it is absolutely correct
when people say that even though the
vaccines the current vaccines do not
give perfect protection against omicron
much less so than against the previous
variants it is still the right thing to
do to become vaccinated and if necessary
to also have a booster dose because that
strengthens your immune system and that
allows you should you become infected
to not to go on to have severe disease
so that is what we we think we are
seeing currently in south africa and
this is where europe also needs to get
to in order to weather this this new
omicron storm that's ahead
and yet this winter is for many going to
be a bad case of deja vu um what needs
to be done so that we don't con continue
to see the development of variants like
omicron disrupt life at this scale
so so firstly i i think for for europe
and winter is of course a tough time
i i think a degree of of
lockdowns and intensified measures is
unavoidable and that's being introduced
in many countries already um but
secondly i mean the big way out of this
without risking even further loss of
life and health and let's not forget
even people who survive and spend weeks
in intensive care or have gone on to
develop long covey
you know they have a very rough ride
it's it's it's not a harmless infection
at all so the way out of this is is
universal vaccination so we all need to
get into the new age where we all will
become infected with
sars kobe 2 the positive virus
probably many times in our lives but
when we enter that phase which is the
endemic phase we need to have good
baseline immunity and the best way to
get that without risking you know severe
disease is of course vaccination and in
future i hope also we will have
updated vaccines that include and give
better protection against omicron which
will make that better but at the time
for the time being uh really i i i fully
agree to the to the peace to to please
become vaccinated if you haven't done so
and get your booster doses as the best
way to counter omicron but still be
ready to become infected because this
virus is is very capable of of evading
the immune response okay clear call to
get vaccinated there from dr wolfgang
preiser virologist from south africa's
university of stellenboss thanks so much
for coming on dw news